so let's start again let's get rid of
all this now I asked you before to try
and think about this question without
trig expansions okay but I'm you are now
enlightened year 11s who knows reactions
so what might you do it this did okay
well the first thing your your knee-jerk
reaction might be well let's expand it
shall we
okay so sine a plus B is okay good
okay get used to it all right now you
look at this you think okay this is um
this is partly good this is partly
better because I've got a sine a sine B
here both of which I know the values off
right so I can sub them in okay but then
you realize you've made things better
and worse at the same time cuz you've
got these collars terms hanging around
right so so what am I supposed to do
with them well if think about something
like sine a rooster 305 oh this is not
just a mathematical equation that's
sitting out there in a vacuum it's
describing a real angle somewhere right
now sine a equals three or five I know a
is cute right so that means I can stick
a in a triangle okay assign sign which
ratio is that that's which sides needs a
pair of opposite hypotenuse right so
sine a is three over five opposite over
hypotenuse sine a is 3 over 5 okay
checks out right so whatever this thing
I don't know what the size is well it
should be roughly 30 so ever whatever we
worked out before this is the ratio of
God and this is a right angle triangle
right that's what makes these trig
ratios work that's what we first looked
at midnight so therefore by that logic
the third side should be
so therefore I do know what 28 is right
sign a actually implies what caused a
use so from this triangle I can say plus
a is 4 or 5 and you can use the same
logic came out right ok so 7 over 25
it's obviously a different triangle this
be ok 7 is the opposite side and 25 is
the hypotenuse which makes the other
side 24 and it's a usually these
questions come up with less recognizable
Pythagorean triads ok so there you go
that tells me because b is equal to so
any 4 okay sine a sine B cos a cos B
over all my pieces
okay so let's give it a go absolutely
let's just substitute it in this is the
easy part
okay sine a is 3 over 5 Cosby is 24 over
25 plus cos n is 4/5 times sine B which
is 7 so 33 by 24 is 72 Thank You war by
7 is 28 and of course they're all over
the same denominator which is 125 and
that's a hundred if I can head out my
numbers right oh not you again
I'm just doing the hip sausage oh okay
sure
thank you I'm holding my breath I can't
click on all this right okay all right
so you can you can see it now there
there is my for you content did you see
what right so it's not just it's not
magic it's not magic at all
it's the expansion okay okay now you
remember I told you I would come back to
this domain business later on okay why
did they have to say this like if I got
rid of this
most of these that looks like you can
still work right well okay I'm going to
illustrate why it's important by
changing it a little bit okay
so let's suppose let's pick on let's
make B let's take P and let's suppose
that it might cute but obtuse okay so
what would I have to say about its
domain two obtuse
what's it between 90 and 180 which is
okay and so this is by the way one of
the reasons why you've gotta watch out
for this domain in as in many other
questions the domain will totally change
your answer okay let's give it a go
these things here are they break down
why do they break down so it's not that
isn't a problem a because I haven't
changed it okay but there is a problem a
big problem
be yeah okay sir my trig ratios they
worked because I have 90 degrees right
but in any case I can't make a right
angle try them
yeah I can't make a triangle with a 90
wrangle an obtuse angle right because
you're like here's my obtuse angle and
he's my he's my um he's my right angle
and and they do some beans if I try to
know okay so what so what am I gonna do
instead okay cause still has a value
it's does a value if it's on a twos it's
just that a cup fit it into this kind of
triangle now think with me think cause
it'd be okay what does cause look like
cause as a graph this is right I've got
two PI over here I've got pine yeah and
that makes this point over here peyote
yes between pi on two and pi that's this
this plot here I'm interested in right
PI's sorry enough hi COS of that angle
is negative keep cos e because there's
there's my angle and there's this cause
of my angle which is negative okay and
that's why by the way it weren't fit
into a nice triangle because the ratio
is naked it goes in a different
direction now here's the thing we can
use triangles but you just need to draw
the right type and you're actually
hopefully familiar with these you need
to draw this old friend let me show you
how it works
I can't have Cubs are so special so I'm
gonna do all my a just the same because
a is women's your own pilot ooh that's
this quadrant here so here's here's the
way it works there's a there's my right
angle to do
okay and it's still three four five but
be because it's in the second quarter
enhancement plan it's gonna be over here
so I don't drop my triangle the same way
I did before I'm gonna try to draw it
off in this direction okay now when you
think about okay if B is over for young
and sine B is 7 over 25 7 over 25 that's
opposite on hypotenuse
but now when you're working out this
third side you see this is the point of
using this diagram right as I'm working
at this side it goes to the left of the
origin these values are negative right
so this is not 24 I'm gonna break a rule
of measurement here this is minus 24
it's going in a different direction okay
I mean it makes sense this 7 is a
positive 7 because I'm going up
does that make sense okay and if I go
down here it'll be a negative value for
sine because that's why C sine is
negative down no it does it because
distance from the origin here comes from
the square root okay which is positive
okay so 25 stays it stays positive okay
all right I'll keep going
so therefore Cosby is not 24 25 it's
negative 24
okay so you can see this is what changes
your answer to the question over here
the method is much the same but my
substitution would just be a little bit
different so this 24 here will be minus
24 so this 72 we - 72
so what's that negative 24 I think
and I don't think you can do much with
no right that's it now here's my point
right see now you understand why that's
the case your calculator when you do
sine inverse of whatever or it's causing
this or whatever right it doesn't tell
you the value that you want it just
tells you the first value okay and it
has two because it doesn't know which
value do one it could be any of these
great trig functions go on forever so
when you're like sine inverse of 3 or 5
it could be this one or this one or this
one or this one or not
so calculate plantain or them so just
touch with the first one so does that
make sense this is the method that we go
through okay and if I change the
question and I said well don't tell me
the COS expect sorry the sine expansion
tell me the COS expansion you would just
use a different expansion here but it'll
be the same numbers going into there
okay they just be substituted in a
different order okay